Ryan Murphy, you son of a bitch.
"You son of a bitch."
Yes, another season of "American Horror Story"
has come to an end and I'll be perfectly honest:
I really enjoyed it.
If you like the campiness, pardon the pun,
and if you're also like me who grew up
watching cheesy '80s slasher movies,
this season was such a
fun homage to those films.
I would even put this season in my Top 3.
Yes, I know that statement will
automatically get me some dislikes.
That being said, the ending,
although good, was not great,
leaving a lot to be desired
both plot- and character-wise.
So in this video, I'm gonna go over how
"American Horror Story: 1984" should have ended.
"Five, six, seven, eight!"
Now before we get into this new ending,
we have to go over an important ground rule:
episode one to eight will remain unchanged.
This isn't because I think they're
perfect, that's not the case at all,
it's just that if I started cherry-picking
things here and there to change,
this video would get super
complicated and I want to avoid that.
Now that we've got that out of the way,
we need to focus on those aspects of
the finale that I think need to be changed.
And I'll focus more on broad criticisms
than nitpicking minor things like,
Oh, I wish Xavier had more air time.
I see you Cody Fern fans out there.
My three main criticisms are as follows:
One, the curse of Camp Redwood
was never fully explored or resolved.
Two, some of the most important character arcs,
namely Brooke and Ricky, were deeply unsatisfying.
And finally, the lack of
tie-ins to other AHS seasons.
The curse of Camp
Redwood is an enigma to me,
with rules that seem to switch episode to episode in order for certain plot points to be hit by the writers.
Like how long does it
take for a body to resurrect?
That kind of changes
throughout the season.
How can Lavinia seemingly teleport?
Where did Jingles go
at the end of episode 8?
For now, let's focus on what we do know about
this curse and build our ending around that.
One, it started in 1948 with the death of Bobby
Richter and her mother's subsequent murder spree,
resulting in Benjamin
killing his own mother.
This is why we don't have any super old-timey ghosts, which would hint that the curse goes way before '48.
After the massacre and death of Lavinia,
anyone killed within the Camp Redwood property
is resurrected as a ghost for all eternity.
It's essentially their own limbo.
In the current ending, there's no real resolution
to this curse, when I think there should be.
If Lavinia gets Bobby back and patches things up
with Ben, the curse theoretically should be lifted.
But the ending we got, the
campers were still stuck at Redwood.
We'll get to how I'll change this in a bit.
Character arcs were also a big problem
for me, mainly those of Brooke and Ricky.
Brooke starts off the
season as our main protagonist,
yet the final episode has her hiding
away, marrying a dermatologist,
and her only real purpose in the episode is to exposition-dump everything that happened to her since 1989.
Ricky, although he doesn't have quite an arc, since
his character is pretty static throughout the season,
didn't get an ending
worthy of his evil character.
By that I mean he could
have gotten it a lot worse.
Now I don't mean physically, since
his death was quite brutal, but emotionally.
An emotional betrayal of sorts by someone
he admires more than anyone else.
We'll get to that too.
And finally the ending missed some great
opportunities to tie in previous AHS seasons.
AHS is known for connecting tons of characters
from different seasons to one another,
and I think they could have
exploited this much more,
particularly Ricky's relationship to
Satan tying in to "Apocalypse."
Okay, you've heard my critiques, now I'm gonna
show you how I think this season should have ended.
Keep in mind my ending is batshit
insane, but hey, so was the season.
It likely has its own
problems, I wrote this in a day,
and it likely wouldn't happen due to,
well, you'll just have to keep watching.
Let's get into it.
We start just like the original ending: a grown up
Bobby Richter has arrived at Camp Redwood in 2019,
searching for answers about his father.
Whereas the original has him meet Montana and
Trevor, in my version he meets Jingles, his dad.
One of the things I didn't like about the original was
that Bobby and Jingles hug once and that's about it.
In my way, it allows them to
connect a bit more before the big finale,
so that when things finally get resolved, we feel more attached to them and it's more emotional, less forced.
Well, Jingles will go on to say that he and the
other ghosts are stuck for eternity at Camp Redwood.
Their souls will never be at rest.
The curse was supposed to be lifted
when Lavinia was reunited with Bobby,
but some evil force is preventing the ghosts, aka
the other campers and counselors, from moving on.
It's here the other ghosts reveal themselves
to Bobby as we flash back to 1989
to hear the story of what
happened at the festival.
Trevor will have blocked the road,
preventing the festival goers from getting in,
but it's here none other than
Billy Idol arrives in his tour bus,
played, of course, by Evan Peters, but
someone else should he not be available.
He's flown all the way
from the UK and is pissed.
What do you mean
the festival's canceled?
He gave up a meeting with the Queen
to be here. Will he still be getting paid?
He storms past Trevor onto the Camp Redwood
grounds in search of Margaret, demanding answers.
I like this version, because the original built up Billy Idol for almost three episodes and there was no payoff.
Billy can also be used plot-wise to manipulate
Ricky, since we know how much he loves him.
"Billy Idol's the truth, man."
Montana will exploit this by telling Ricky
she's arranged a private meeting with him,
away from all the other less devoted fans,
and this could take place in Lavinia's shack
where the other ghosts wait for him,
trapping him in there
similar to the original.
We flash forward back to present day
where Jingles brings his son to see Ricky,
who they have tied up and confined in his
own satanic cell for the past 30 years.
This scene could be fun since
you'll have Ricky taunting Bobby,
saying he'll get his revenge and saying
how he enjoyed carving up his mother,
but the real purpose of this
scene is to highlight how
whatever satanic power is trapped within
Ricky is preventing the curse from being lifted.
The ghosts have tried everything,
but Ricky keeps coming back to life
with his satanic spirit trapped within him.
If they can somehow remove this demonic force
from his body, maybe they can break the curse.
In the meantime, they've done the only thing they
can: keep him confined so he can't escape Redwood.
Bobby is now determined.
He says he'll find a way to lift the
curse and save the other ghosts.
After all, it was his
father and the other ghosts
who have been protecting him in the world
all these years from the evil that is Ricky.
It's the least he can do.
Jingles tells Bobby to start his quest with
Donna Chambers at the Red Meadows Asylum.
She may have some answers.
Bobby visits Donna at the asylum,
similar to how he did in the original.
Here, we'll have Donna recount how Brooke
and her got the revenge and killed Margaret,
but my version has an injured Brooke
being taken to the camps edge by Ray,
only for her to be saved by none other than
Billy Idol, whose tour bus is still there.
As we flash-forward, Bobby
says he thought Brooke didn't survive.
He searched everywhere for a Brooke
Thompson, but couldn't find one.
That's because she's no
longer Brooke Thompson.
Are you ready for this? She's Brooke Idol.
Yes, the girl who started as a virgin with the
squeaky-clean lifestyle has come full circle,
marrying one of the most
badass singers in rock'n'roll.
A marriage that would have had to be kept secret, since Brooke is still considered to be dead from death row.
Bobby goes to the gates outside Billy's
mansion and is turned away by the guard,
who thinks he's a crazy fan shouting
things about ghosts and Camp Redwood,
kind of like how he was
turned away at the asylum.
But Brooke will overhear this and bring him
inside, where Bobby will plead with her to go back.
They need to save the
others and stop Ricky for good.
The curse of Redwood needs to be lifted.
And he doesn't know who to turn to.
Back at Redwood, a few days later,
Chet and Bertie are on the night shift,
looking after Ricky, just like the original,
when they are viciously
murdered by none other than Billy Idol.
But as we'll find out, spoiler alert,
this is all part of the plan.
It's not a big deal to kill Chet and Bertie,
since they'll just resurrect again.
Ricky is astonished to see his true hero
helping him out of his confinement,
Billy saying that Satan talked to
him and ordered him to set Ricky free,
that Satan isn't done with him.
Billy tells him a boat is waiting for them at the dock and that they'll finally be free once they get off the property.
As they get down to the dock,
Ricky remarks, "Where's the boat?"
But it's all a trap, revealing
Cordelia at the other end of the dock.
Yes, the Cordelia Goode
from "Coven" and "Apocalypse."
If there's anyone who can
deal with satanic beings it's her,
and you know I had to
bring our girl Paulson back.
As we'll find out, Billy is actually a
warlock who attended Hawthorne,
hence how he would know Cordelia,
and we could also tie this
into his success as a rockstar.
Cordelia will cast a spell, lifting Ricky into the air as
the demonic spirit escapes from his throat and mouth.
The other ghost from the season emerge from
the forest, watching as these events unfold,
including both Bobby, Jingles,
Lavinia, and Bobby Jr., all side by side.
With a final blow, the
demonic entity is destroyed,
casting the entire lake
and forest in bright white light,
Ricky's body collapsing
on the edge of the dock.
The curse has been lifted
and Ricky is now mortal.
Billy takes Ricky's curved
knife, ready to end him for good.
It's the biggest betrayal for Ricky,
his hero being the one to kill him,
when Brooke swerves in
and guts him in the stomach.
After all, it was Ricky who
first tried to kill her in episode 1.
With blood coming out from his mouth,
his face of betrayal turns to an evil smirk
as he recites Billy's lyrics from his song
"Rebel Yell", saying, "More, more, more,"
as Montana and the other
ghosts stab him mercilessly.
We get a goodbye between Jingles and Bobby,
before a mysterious force slowly pulls
the ghost towards the center of the lake.
Cordelia, Bobby, Brooke, and Billy watch
as the ghosts disappear above the lake,
their souls finally put to rest and
the curse of Redwood finally lifted.
I would have loved to have months
working on a better ending than this one,
but hey, with a half day and not having to worry about whether Evan Peters or Sarah Paulson could come back,
I thought this would be a fun
exercise for all of us AHS fans out there.
If you enjoyed it, I would love it if you
gave it a like and made a comment.
And make sure to subscribe, since I have tons of
other videos coming up before the next AHS season.
You can also follow me
on Twitter @ThinkStoryYT.
Until next time remember,
Daddy loves you very much.